the US war in Afghanistan has been going
on for nearly 16 years president Trump
has so far rejected the proposals from
his national security adviser for the
next steps they're speaking this week
about the conflict Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson said quote to just say
we're going to keep doing what we've
been doing president is just not willing
to accept that correct princess founded
what was once a security firm Blackwater
he wants to send about 5,000 private
military contractors to replace troops
helping the Afghan army he believes his
plan would cost would cut the annual
cost of the war to less than 10 billion
dollars for an estimated 45 billion he's
now executive director and chairman of
frontier services group good morning
good morning
explain to us why you think this work
but lots of governments listen to this
and they say mercenaries and they're
opposed shirk of mercenaries I think any
American left right or center wants to
figure out a way to put an end to the
war in Afghanistan right now you're
spending more than the entire UK defense
budget the United States is just in
Afghanistan so we've had as many as a
hundred and forty thousand troops now
they're at about nine thousand troops
and 26,000 contractors that the US has
and as secretary mattis said we're not
winning there so to restructure that as
they laid out in the Wall Street Journal
article you have to put someone clearly
in charge the interagency process you've
had 17 different commanders in 15 years
that's not even counting ambassadors or
CIA station chief so you have to have
one person that is clearly in charge of
all US policy spending rules of
engagement of the effort there's the US
official in the State Department or
something like that it'd be a super
envoy a presidential envoy a lead
federal official we've not had any unity
of command for 17 years second the u.s.
is not doing any training or mentoring
really at the battalion level where the
rubber really meets the road so this
plan as they lay out puts contracted
people attaching them to the Afghan army
for the long term at the battalion level
living with training with our these
control people going to be boots on the
ground there yes in the battle and are
they by definition therefore mercenaries
hired by the US government actually the
way the United Nations defines
mercenaries by being attached to the
Afghan army they would
be mercenaries so there would be
contracted people professionals former
Special Special Operations veterans that
have experience in that theater to go do
that work and so what his mattes think
of this he likes the analysis of the
problem but he doesn't necessarily like
the idea that you'd send contractors he
doesn't like your idea but he likes the
idea as he has said you know Afghan war
we're not winning yes well he said that
but he's also said I'm told that you
know the mentoring at the ground level
air support and governance support those
three things they lay out in that plan
that basically puts a patch it puts
training wheels on the Afghan forces and
keeps them upright and lets you it would
set the stage for the drawdown of the
9,000 Americans and 26,000 other
contractors to go from 45 billion in
spend to less than ten that supports
your Afghan forces and it keeps us
Special Operations Forces there as well
so general McMaster also very skeptical
about this plan as our Afghan officials
Afghanistan's ambassador said to me
contractors simply do not win wars you
need their buy-in in order to have your
men if they go into the situation
protected legally how do you persuade
them look contractors are there a big
way now this is a slight alteration of
how there'd be used into combat like
situations sure but it's not a private
army they're they're attaching to the
Afghan army they're basically imagine
them as skeletal support on which the
each Afghan battalion is built around
look the US sorry the the Afghan Special
Forces are functional they they do well
they conduct 70 80 percent of the
offensive missions they are mentored in
exactly this way by US Special Forces
the problem is the US Army does not have
enough sergeants they can't send 4,000
sergeants and above to go do this
mission wasn't the strategy Eric to help
the Afghan spike the war themselves I've
been the strategy for 15 years it is
named as long as this character in
history and this completes that strategy
when US forces bill there they go there
for six or nine months and when they
leave all that local area knowledge and
experience leaves with them this this
model allows contractors to go in but it
should be with the Afghans they should
happen
the point I agree but just but but but
putting mentors in at the battalion
level allows them to attach and to know
that area to know that Valley to know
the the local government officials in
that area that gives you multi-year
continuity because when a u.s. guy goes
in like I said it goes in for nine
months and he leaves and that and that
local knowledge leaves with him this has
been a really long drawn-out process for
the Trump administration they're still
struggling with this strategy
Steve Bannon Jared Kushner said to be
very supportive of your idea do you know
what the president thinks I don't I
haven't briefed him on it yet but do you
plan to I I hope to look they're still
Americans dying there I think like I
said any American left right or center
wants to figure out a way to cauterize
this this wound 16 years is enough we
have another trillion dollars in health
care costs that we're going to owe for
the Afghan war so let's bring it to a
close people might like people might not
like the idea of using contractors for
that let's let's get used to that idea
it's better than having American
soldiers there endlessly are we gonna
are we going to be having this
conversation in another 10 years you
know I have a question about your firm
global security services could that
company be involved and wouldn't that
present a conflict of interest look if
it comes to a bid or whatever if if
someone's able to come up with a
solution that saves the taxpayers forty
billion dollars I think anyone should
compete and do that would take me
profiting from the war well we're not
there now but any vendor that again that
solves that solution that's that's
capitalism that's that's what it's about
so you believe your sister is in the
administration of course education teri
Betsy DeVos that would not preclude you
from being able to bid on this to be of
course not one other question about
Blackwater - a form of black work
colleagues had their sentence overturned
yes I do you expect the third no what
happened to the the guys murder
conviction was thrown out that was the
second time the Justice Department tried
to prosecute him and the the the
sentence that was thrown that the other
three guys was also thrown out for being
cruel and unusual under the Eighth
Amendment so what remains
it managed to determine whether what
sentences those guys do get now they
have to go for resentencing doesn't this
raise concerns about how would you
tackle this kind of situation in
Afghanistan sure you need to get those
legal protections because that's what
and and have they probably defined
clearly defined accountability method
you could use the UCMJ okay I think the
the military court of justice uniform
Uniform Code of Military Justice a
military trial in Afghanistan under US
military law any contractor that goes to
do that job would be happy to sign up
for that you'd have to negotiate that
with Afghan government sure and they're
skeptical but you think you can win them
over the Afghan government doesn't want
to be abandoned they know I mean look
there's the argument to say just pull
out of Afghanistan completely that would
be bad
I think within six months or 12 months
you see a Taliban flag happened last
time you know being abandoned yes sure
in a reason question all the time and if
that happens in Afghanistan that's a
rally cry for every crazy jihadi around
the world thank you for coming here
thank you Thanks